good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast today
and
happy
Friday Friday
gotta get down on Friday everybody's
looking forward to the weekend weekend
Friday Friday getting down on Friday
hey
how you learn during good happy Friday
everyone we made it we went through a
little hump in the latter half of the
week not even not yet this has been a
week it has been a week but doing video
emergency room
right flashlight oh good yeah my first
period
Jackie O being hit by the sinus
infection
my God every day it's something else
passport
that was kind of like a win for us not
really Passport to Paris such a good
movie I have to go back and watch all
those Mary Kate and Ashley movies I've
actually been getting like clips of them
on my tick tock
they're so good they age so well I
watched them a few years ago maybe it
was during covet or maybe it was before
and like they are truly masterpieces
like
I wouldn't change a thing what do you
think is the best one
it just depends on like your Vibe and
what kind of City you want to be in I
think our lips are sealed as utter
Perfection
but so is Holiday in the Sun like the
commercial for Atlantis yeah Passport to
Paris is great
New York minute is unreal but they're a
little older they're more mature it's a
little more exciting yeah no the New
York minute one is a kind of advanced
you know they're skipping school they're
kissing boys they're kind of like Fast
yeah no they're kind of like loose
well just the one and the other one has
to be pushed into it right right but you
know in the end it ends up being good
for both of them yeah they're all really
amazing except for winning London that
one like just doesn't
stick with me I don't even remember that
one what's the plot they're like doing
like they're part of mock trial or
something and their team goes to London
not Macho what's the other one uh model
un model un it was something like this I
was on model un yeah so they're a model
un and the competitions in London and
the competition is stiff
by the way I went to a model un
competition in high school it is stiff I
think that like model un probably
accomplishes more than the actual un
yeah no and I really learned a lot about
the inner workings of the UN
um I kind of had like an irrelevant
country which was annoying because like
the topic at hand was like Iran and
nuclear like it was a serious topic
given for the for the uh the conference
and I was Mongolia and when I tell you
like no one remains less affected in
like world news than Mongolia like they
just they're like a small farm cut like
they just really had nothing to say but
like your grade and your participation
is based on your what you contribute so
I'm like making [__] up about the kids
and it was a transformative experience
was it hard for you to not really be
like a star player in the Iran nuclear
negotiations I was like I either want to
be Iran
America
or like Russia or I'm out of here you
could be Israel you could be really any
nuclear power yeah because then you have
say right and I had literally no say and
they said it was like random assignments
of
of the countries but I like got really
into my un I think me and my friends
like tried out partially as a joke but
also we were Juniors like you just
needed to like stack your resume for
college so we were like you know we were
like no one's going to join model un and
we all like got to the audition and I
was the only one who made it and like I
actually loved it and it was just like I
stumbled into a passion of mine are you
supposed to be a diplomat
I
the thing is I'm not very diplomatic
like the part of being a diplomat that
like requires you to be diplomatic is
not my strong suit but the part where
you get on the floor like fight for your
rights oh that's so me yeah I see that
for you I feel like we'd be a good it's
never just like one person that
represents it's just like yes literally
it's one person represents the country
but there's always like a team of people
at the table where people have like
different strengths even in like the UN
there's obviously a speaker translator
et cetera Etc
um I feel like we'd be a good team
because I don't want the floor but I am
extremely diplomatic and you get like a
weirdly a lot of perks as a diplomat
like I think you get like immunity from
like crimes and [__] yeah and you get
like housing in your in like a foreign
country and it's usually like the
Ambassador houses in New York City are
like Town Homes they're kind of gorgeous
there is a delicacy
is that the right word is it one person
or no like the country of some country
owns the entire floor in my building so
like the embassy yeah no but it's like
for the diplomats that's where they live
when they come to town and you can't I
think the diplomats live in the embassy
this is literally password to Paris
Shaggy they don't live in the embassy
the embassy is like for people who are
first from your country yes but no
Travelers
why wouldn't they live at the embassy
like shorten the commute
I mean for sure because it's an office
building but then they also have like
residences and one of the residences is
in my building and you by the way like
one of the it's like impossible to get
to only one of the elevators goes and it
has like a secret code I've never seen
it and actually I don't even know
because Ben was the one who told me that
like he actually met some one of the
delegates and they told him and it was
like a whole big secret it's like kind
of like a crazy thing it is but that is
Passport to Paris I'm pretty sure their
dad like got is a delegate yeah he's a
diplomat and they live in like this
mansion
with their chef yeah privilege privilege
Mary Kate and Ashley were totally
privileged when they were when on
Holiday in the Sun they flew to Bahamas
they flew private oh yeah yeah you're
right
like they didn't even try
to be like too relatable in the movies
yeah yeah yeah kind of love that for
them it's like where these twin
billionaires deal with it
yeah I get what I want and this winter
break I want Jordan sucks to suck ah
such an iconic Moment In Time Justice
for the kids today he'll never have that
no they have crap crap actually you know
what they do have even though it's not
for kids but I'm just trying to segue I
started a new show last night um on HBO
Max it's called the other two
the [__] is that I'm surprised nobody
like and I was surprised to see somebody
told me to watch it I'm like oh it must
be like you know the first couple of
episodes no we're like well into season
two I've doubted like I haven't heard a
thing about it but it's produced by
Lauren Michaels and it stars Molly
Shannon and basically Molly Shannon has
three kids two older ones and one
younger one and the younger one becomes
like overnight like a Justin Bieber he
like posts this video and the other two
kids are like you know one of them's an
aspiring actor but he's you know failing
and he's just like you know going to
auditions in between ships at a
restaurant and the other is like this
failed dancer and she doesn't know what
to do with her life and they don't know
what to do because their brother is like
becoming so rich and famous and the
writing oh my God it is hysterical there
was like this seat and it's like kind of
stacked like Wanda Sykes is in it they
um they sit the family down and have
this binder they had a PR Company go
through like all the bad things that
they've ever done that could reflect
poorly
on Chase the younger brother and the
daughter obviously had like this huge
binder full of problematic [__] she
never did and they were like did you
dress as Terry shivo for Halloween
it was such a niche reference like I
hadn't heard the name Terry Shiva in so
many years the writing is very funny I
actually think you would like it oh my
God I think I would like it too that
sounds really funny I have seen one
commercial for it so I know like the
Justin Bieber thing like I have heard of
that right um just but I thought it was
maybe even a movie like I never saw it
or heard about it again I started a new
show yesterday too because I was sick
and I was like what is something I've
been saying I'll watch but I don't have
the time and there were like a million
things I'm like I still don't want to
watch him
but I started Abbott Elementary because
everybody said that I would like it and
based on what I've seen about it it
looks like I would like it and it's won
so many awards so it's like okay
and then it turned like it's like it's
just a quick sitcom which is exactly
what I wanted on my sick day really easy
to get into I thought it was really cute
and really funny there are some really
funny moments I mean Mrs Howard is my
queen yeah like
period I don't want to hear anything
from anyone and you by the way you
literally are Mrs Howard I literally am
Mrs Howard yeah and Miss teague's is
just so annoying that who's Miss T
Quinta brunson's characters oh my God
like
I know she's the protagonist in every
episode she like learns her lesson and
she's just like this ogre Eager Beaver
right he just doesn't understand like
how things actually work she just lives
in like Fairyland and wants things to be
perfect like Mrs Howard is working with
what she has it's so true this is Howard
is a realist and that's me what do you
think about the principal because when I
watched everyone was like the principal
is so funny I found her to be so
annoying I find her to be annoying but
she has some good moments yeah the
writing on the show is very good like
it's very funny yeah there are just some
really funny like tropes and characters
of course um Chessie is in it playing
like this sexy Italian woman yeah who
means business
but I thought it was really good I think
I probably watched like Eight Episodes
and I really enjoyed it it's nice to
just have like a sitcom on that's
you know not gonna make me
feel down or up or anything just like
you know how most people watch friends
or 30 rockets and there's so many
campers yeah and the campers are cute
but I feel like we don't get to know the
campers on an individual level like we
never hear from the same camper twice in
two different episodes no it's so true
the campers are not like kind of they're
kind of like transient extras I guess
that's how teachers not not how they
feel about their students but it's like
you have them for one year and then it's
a whole new batch like it's really not
about them it's really about the
Teachers Lounge drama right which is why
I'm desperate to be a teacher I know I
have to get to the teacher's lounge is
this making you want to be a teacher
more or less
um both there are certain aspects and
I'm like oh that's [__] torture like
you know the kids peeing on the carpet
we don't have budget for new carpets
no thank you like just like the thought
of like the books being like all sticky
from like kid Paws um
but the love of the campers the Teachers
Lounge moderate like the vending machine
guy and Melissa
I need to be there it's exciting yeah I
guess none of the like really tea tree
aspects are what make me want to be a
teacher I guess no no not at all it's
just like all the perks all the perks
I'm sure the teachers listening are like
yeah all the perks of being a teacher
yeah yeah yeah
um well I'm so glad you finally started
that feels nice to check something off
your list yeah even though like the list
is so long it's like OBX season three
White Lotus
okay here's the thing with White Lotus
like part of the fun is being you know
watching it with everyone else and you
know being a part of something and
guessing and theories all in the moment
I honestly don't think you like you're
genuinely too late yeah no there have
been so many times where it's like I've
sit down to watch something and I can I
have the time and it's like White Lotus
is on my list and I just continue to
bypass it like yeah you can I probably
remove it from your life yeah it's
pretty much removed but it's it's just
there just in case you know in an
emergency I need to download a show for
a flight like what are you gonna do
right right but still I know who dies so
oh
because she spoiled it in her speech and
now I've just ruined it for you
yeah if you're listening and with a keen
ear
um so we've got a great show it's so
great to be back in studio with you Jax
there's I really hate podcasting from
home like it's really toxic I did not
leave my house yesterday like I don't
I'm not like a big you know leave the
house sir but when I do leave the house
every day for the toast I'm getting my
required oxygen my required vitamin D
the bare minimum I didn't get that
yesterday and like when I went to bed I
was not okay
yeah you need to leave your house in
order to appreciate being in your house
you need to work for it for words you
need to earn it yeah you need to earn it
for me yesterday the only difference
between yesterday and today was
obviously feeling sick but just not
putting on makeup because I still
recorded in my studio looking at my
gorgeous turdy Lou
on the screen right here but
yeah I'm feeling like still without
doing makeup and like video it just
doesn't feel the same I just you know
even though for people who listen as a
podcast which is the majority of you
nothing is different no that's the thing
like yesterday to me was so different it
was like a crazy radical opposite day
opposite day everything's upside down
and I always forget like literally a
fifth of our audience watches maybe
maybe less on YouTube so like as long as
we're putting out premium audio like
most of our audience remains unaffected
but to me like the big deal is like the
studio the bright lights lights camera
action yeah because we're obsessed with
being on camera because we're just like
egomaniacs maniacs
Maniacs we're like oh no there's people
watching on YouTube we must do video and
we must and we do and we will yeah yeah
plus for the reels now everyone's doing
it I know like it's so fun being ahead
of the curve yeah like we've always done
video and audio so when we made the gem
to Reels it was a no-brainer but now
people who've only ever done audio have
to record themselves in order to make
these reels that's what's so interesting
about like the podcasting landscape
that's really actually confusing to me
is like in the last year podcasting has
gotten even bigger you know we're in
more households and podcasting has
really taken over but unless you're a
podcast that films you are irrelevant
like it's crazy to me how the medium at
its core is audio focused but like the
biggest and the best and really a way to
get ahead is to video it
I'm trying to think
of podcasts I don't think I don't think
the daily
does like literally who even does the
daily I like who hosts I don't know I
don't know a name I don't know a face
yeah me neither it's a faceless podcast
yeah but like the big podcasts are all
done on video yeah especially like in
comedy which is really what I compare
ourselves to yeah I'm sure in the top
like the crime ones don't do video yeah
and the newsy ones like the Daily News
ones like NPR yeah but like everybody's
radio Heather McDonald does video
does Smart list do video they should
good question I feel like they don't
because we would see their Clips because
they have like the biggest celebrities
in the world you're so right
office ladies
I feel like they don't I can't believe
they're so big you know like the off
like it's just there's so many recap
podcasts and like well I think one
people left the office but two they must
be great podcasters because it's not
enough to just be like a beloved
re-watch show plus their interview their
most recent episode is an interview with
Will Ferrell and like he's not even on
the office so it must be I feel like
they kind of evolved past it the office
and Beyond I should tell Zach to listen
to that because he loves the office
uh David Spade and Dana Carvey have a
podcast that's number five today I don't
think they do video
of our faves Tom Segura and Christina
video they do video Theo vonda's video
oh my God I have recently stumbled into
Theo Von stanhood
um I like never like had even heard of
him and then I went down such a [__]
Rabbit Hole he did an episode of in bed
with Joan remember that what okay but
who is he primarily
a comic a comic turn podcaster turned
actor like does a bunch of stuff so when
Joan had him on he was just a comic a
stand-up comic who I think had just
released a movie or something okay
and he looks so different I was shook he
didn't have the mullet no
and he's kind of like and it
he's so different now like even his
brand of Comedy has evolved so much I
was like who is this guy
um but thanks to tick tock like I was
served so many clips of his podcast he's
always saying the most out of pocket
[__] and he makes any conversation like
the way we can let the good guys turn
any conversation into like about food or
Judaism he will turn any conversation
into this kid he grew up with in his
neighborhood like oh there was a kid in
my neighborhood who was blind like he oh
there's a kid in his neighborhood for
everything and it's so funny he's so
funny and I really am so late but I'm
just discovering yeah that is so funny
and I'm I'm glad he's going viral and
that you're discovering him that way
because that's what we're hoping for for
us of course the reals like I never
would have thought like turdy Lou Theo
Von Stan
but that's what reels do they bring
people together and they target you
especially Tick Tock algorithm I was
targeted by Tim Dylan videos is that how
you discovered Tim Dillon I said maybe
on Twitter first
yeah I'm trying to think of the Genesis
but like I think it was like he had some
funny tweets and then he went on Joe
Rogan and I happened to be doing like a
road trip so it was like one of the more
recent episodes I was like oh this guy's
funny like on Twitter I'll listen right
Zach and I were crying crying and then
like he has his own podcast and I
started following him on Instagram
because he posts like videos from his
episode and just the videos are so funny
and then we just like send them back and
forth so yeah I've been targeted turdy
Lou I'm a Target no and I feel like
people are always asking us for like
podcast advice or whatever and the
advice is like if you ain't a reals
people you ain't a real people you ain't
real people yeah
that's my advice of the day business
advice once your podcast stick is in a
good place you're talking about
interesting things you're having a fresh
unique take on something and you're not
just repeating what everyone else is
saying right now and you're not like I
have a hot take
I have a really hot take I know I'm
gonna get canceled for this and they
like do this whole big building and it's
like donuts should be cold
no no because
no no no like like they say something so
obvious you know and like somebody not
even remotely cancelable they say like
let me just wait let me think because
there's like so many
oh okay I got it
this is every podcast these days
say something crazy like hot take coming
your way and honestly like I feel like I
could get canceled for saying this okay
are you sure you want to say it yeah
whatever
the word moist is disgusting it's like
uh okay on original thought not a good
take not a hot take and like boring
yeah
oh four for four four for four
um okay we have like a lot to get into
Selena Gomez is like starting more
trouble the Vanderpump Rules reunion was
yesterday we got some like paparazzi
photos we've got a lot from the reading
we have seating charts
two shirts two seating charts we have a
recap story from Andy Paparazzi pictures
we have as much as we can do it is the
second story not the first they've been
usurped by Selena they've got to keep an
eye out for Selena
that's what I'm currently doing right
now and that's what Theo's been doing
all week how's Theo's eye thank you for
asking it's much better pretty much the
next day it went back to normal once he
had antibiotics in and it hasn't been
bothering him
um but he is still wearing his cone and
like he is so bothered by the cone today
he woke me up at like five in the
morning he went to go scratch his ear
and he was scratching the cone so it was
like nails on vinyl thank God I went
back to sleep
um oh God or else it would be another
episode like too yeah no actually slept
amazing last night I love sleeping in
the bed alone with Theo it's everything
dude tattoo
gorgeous angel
excuse me ready without further Ado
About
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know
today's episode is brought to you by up
here on Hulu up here is a musical series
rom-com about two characters Lindsay and
Miguel who are juggling career and
crushes as they try to find love in New
York City in 1999 featuring original
music up here is a rom-com all about
falling in love and discovering that the
greatest obstacle to finding happiness
together is yourself well yourself and
the treacherous world of obsession fears
memories and Fantasies that live inside
our heads so premieres on Hulu March
24th which is today and what's exciting
about this is that it's from the
director of Hamilton it's from the
screenwriter of tick Tick boom and the
songwriters of the Book of Mormon and
one division so that's Thomas kale from
Hamilton Stephen Levinson from Tick Tick
boom and Kristen and Bobby Lopez from
The Book of Mormon and one division this
is a story about two characters Lindsay
Miguel trying to find love in a big city
it's a story about the opinions of
friends and family and how they can
manifest his voices in your heads up
here takes those inner voices of Family
and friends and shoves them into the
daily lives of these everyday New
Yorkers filled with raunch and
Ridiculousness up here is about that
magical time in your life when you had
nothing figured out and all the time in
which to think about it so it's almost
time for spring which means the spring
musical is upon us and Miss darbus has
selected up here on Hulu as the spring
musical I love content that has original
music it's such a great way to discover
new music new things for your Spotify
um and up here premieres today which is
very exciting so all the episodes of the
musical rom-com up here are now
streaming on Hulu starting today that's
all uh up here up here on Hulu streaming
today and speaking of singing today's
episode is also brought to you by the
bed by fuma now get a 25 credit towards
your purchase of the bed plus free
shipping in the Continental us when you
go to thuma.co toast that's thuma
the bed by Suma handcrafted by
eco-friendly high quality upcycled wood
the bed has a modern minimalist design
that helps Elevate any space it's super
supportive for your mattress it's
breathable and it's made to naturally
minimize noise and create space the bed
is put together using the Timeless
technique of Japanese joinery each piece
locks into place meaning no tools or
excess Hardware are required for
assembly so with clean lines and subtle
curves the bed is simple sophistication
for your bedroom Jackie talk about your
experience using Japanese joinery tell
me about setting up the bed because you
know we are not easily we're not girls
who easily set up Furniture no we're not
but thuma is made for girls like us it's
made for just humans in general who want
wonderful gorgeous furniture and don't
want to spar with their Partners putting
it together so it was really s
shockingly simple to put together the
bed by fuma and now we have this
gorgeous
bed in our guest room that our guests
have been loving the bed by thuma is
backed with a lifetime warranty it ships
right to your door in three easy to
maneuver boxes and takes about five
minutes to assemble with no tools
required and along with the bed thuma
offers other bedroom Essentials to
elevate bedtime like the mattress the
nightstand and the side table and they
all perfectly complement the bed they
also have Financial financing options
available on their website so create
that feeling of checking into your
favorite boutique hotel suite but at
home with the bed by thuma and now go to
thuma.co toast to receive a 25 credit
towards your purchase of the bed plus
free shipping in the continental US
that's thuma t-h-u-m-a dot Co slash
toast for 25 credit thank you turdy Lou
what can I say except yeah welcome
our first story Selena Gomez has posted
to her Instagram story to weigh in on
what is going on between her and Haley
over the last few weeks she posted a
text story that said Haley Bieber
reached out to me and let me know that
she has been receiving death threats and
such hateful negativity this isn't what
I stand for no one should have to
experience hate or bullying I've always
advocated for kindness and really want
this all to stop heart
in the words of you know pop icon JoJo
it's just a little too late a little too
long and I can't wait you know all the
right things to say but you know it's
just too little too late like the wave
of bullying is over like it was uh a
10-day period of Ruthless bullying about
Haley's looks her marriage her business
everything and now you want to come in
and be the hero I don't know it's the
timing ain't right for me but do not
think that Haley recently reached out
like maybe maybe for you it seems like
you know the Articles have died down the
tick tocks you're not seeing as much but
like maybe for Haley like it's still
unmanageable and I think what's so crazy
is like I'm sure the last thing Haley
ever wanted to do was reach out to
Selena and have to be like I need your
help
um but Selena is the only person who
could stop this considering one it's her
fans who have taken up the to their
torches and two she fanned the Flames
for weeks yeah no and um you're right
Selena really is the only one who can
get these people to stop but
they're like and now so once she's
posted that I wanted to see what the
salinators were saying the Jelena fans
um and they're like isn't it funny how
Selena had to post this and like Justin
wouldn't even speak up for Haley like
their marriage is a shame like it's
non-stop like it's still they're
insatiable
what could Justin say that would satiate
these people I don't know I just feel
like also like Justin I mean I'm sure
his wife's mental health is of the
utmost priority for real but like he is
like not okay he's like dealing with
meant with health issues he's like doing
better recently but like on the one hand
I feel like if he posted like a text
story everyone would be like Haley wrote
This and like he really she held a gun
to his head he really can't come on and
do a video because like he's not uh
so he's doing better he had said
recently but I don't think he's like
totally cured I don't know what his
what's going on got it he's still like
suffering a bit so I don't know that he
wants to come on and do a selfie video
please be nicer to my wife no so many
things about this are so weird because
at the end of the day like the fans felt
even more Justified and even more
passionate about going after Haley
Bieber because Selena kind of sang
mentioned it with her comments on social
media
um I do feel like this really is too
late I'm sure the threats are still
coming but it's not the height of it so
I think the timing is weird I'm really
shocked to even hear that Haley reached
out to Selena because I'm sure that's
the last thing on the planet that she
wanted to do and this is just such a
weird series of events yeah
it is
I couldn't believe when I like tap
Selena's story that I saw Haley Bieber's
name like it was just like I never even
thought she would say the words Haley
Bieber like you know I know I just feel
like the volume and the intensity of
messages and threats that she must be
receiving is like Beyond
anything that's been seen before because
always like you know someone gets in
trouble or someone's like this they get
death threats and it's like please stop
I'm getting death threats but like it's
not even Haley saying it like she
literally had to reach out to Selena
like that's how bad it must be I know I
feel really bad for Haley
me too
I hope that I hope that this stops it I
don't have a lot of faith in Selena's
fans yeah sorry sorry to say yeah but I
don't know why them reading this would
give them any more gas to give Haley
hate like Selena said stop
right well no that's their they're
always looking for a way to then
continue to blame and make fun of Haley
Bieber so it's like well Selena had to
post this and she's like trying to
protect Haley and like Justin wouldn't
right that's what they're saying like
it's they're insatiable yeah
leave Hayley Bieber alone I've had
enough
me too but I will say um
her posting like some sickening photos
of herself and making the caption the
Emoji of the ear oh yeah because they
started to say she looks like an ear
yeah and it's like okay let's not like
just be delusional like Haley Bieber is
arguably the most beautiful woman in the
world right now like she looks like an
ear then the [__] do you look like I
wish my ears look like that I have
little Haley's it's like um no I don't
wish my ears look like that I wish I
looked like that what's that um oh yeah
yeah yeah I know aquamarine and little
Whispering compliments in my ears that
movie was also so good perfect perfect I
feel like we've had this conversation
before about how often I think fondly
about Sarah Paxton we have and she was
just in something good I hope she's a
long illustrious career she was in
something that's really big that we
don't watch oh good okay yeah let me
just pull it up quickly because
obviously her iconic roles are
aquamarine and sleepover
sleepover oh okay she was in blonde
what's blonde oh yeah armas Marilyn
Monroe biopic okay I got it that's the
one
that she was so good I'm glad she's
booking roles yeah same
um in terms of this Haley and Selena
nonsense like I pray this is the last we
speak of it I just wish everyone peace
honestly I hope Selena like
like learned a lesson here like the
power of her words like she had to tell
her fans to stop because she told them
to start you know I hope she's putting
that together I don't think she's
putting that together I know because the
fans aren't no these are only people
saying that and we get like hate for
saying because she's like completely
plausibly
deniable in the sense that she never
told them to start she just like you
know was just being a victim all over
social media which in had the effect of
people wanting to defend her but she
would never ever think that that was
instigating anything well I hope we can
all you know take a look at this
situation and realize not only were we
wrong about the content there was
literally hilly and Kylie were never
making fun of Selena Gomez and we know
that now even more with the mascara
launch
um but
you know there are consequences for and
there are ramifications when you get
involved with stuff like this and one of
the ramifications of Selena like you
know leaning into this victim role that
her fans see her in was like the
destruction of somebody's entire life
yeah like there are consequences when
you do things so this was a really bad
look for a lot of people yeah and the
thing is like I said I really don't
expect much from the Selena fans and the
jelena's fans like they're always going
to be just a crazy fandom I don't know
why but what was more disappointing and
surprising was like kind of the adults
in the room and I just feel like
commentators you know pop culture people
like the the Articles were really like
going along with this narrative that
Haley was bullying Selena and it's like
grow up grow like don't you have can't
you see that that's not what's happening
like you really think that that's what's
happening I saw so many reels you know
podcasts hot takes Selena's how is she
how was this how could this be a
coincidence right that's not a hot take
by the way what people need to learn
about the word hot take days because hot
take is when you say something that
nobody else is saying and everybody says
the same [__] they recycle the same
thoughts and be like hot take no bring
me back to my earlier point this is a
hot take because I feel like we're the
only people who are like what the [__]
is going on like nobody was bullying
Selena Selena's playing the victim and
justice for Haley Bieber that's a hot
take [__] that's a hot take Salinas you
really need to learn the [__]
definition of a hot take yeah they do
that's the perfect example of what we
were just talking about 10 minutes ago
yeah
so that was more disappointing just like
there were so few people who could see
the situation clearly and it's like no
but you guys are like grown and you know
how these things work there's no excuse
yeah there's no excuse
anyways let's get into our next story
Vanderpump Rules reunion day was
yesterday Lots has come out even though
I think they've kept as much Under Wraps
as possible but what's so crazy is just
like this these group of people have
been like elevated like they get
followed around by Paparazzi now like
there never would have been TMZ standing
outside the banner pump reunion in the
last 10 years of course but now we're
getting you know pictures of them on
smoke breaks getting out of their cars
seeing their outfits like we usually
don't get to see outfits until Bravo
releases a photo so there's so much
content because there's so much interest
yeah so first Tom and Raquel were
pictured together for the first time
since Sandoval they are talking taking
he's taking a smoke break he's giving
Cole Sprouse with his cigarette
um they're taking us no but by the way
that's just like a fun fact about a lot
of the VPR cast and I feel like back in
the day we saw it a little bit because
they all used to stand outside and do
smoke breaks and that's our parking lot
but like I feel like a lot of them smoke
cigarettes
yeah I think also they smoke when they
drink I think they Vape too they do yeah
it's not that they hide on the show but
I think they do a good job of just like
not showing it so much like if we're
gonna go have a serious conversation
We're not gonna have cigs because we
know it's gonna air but we could go over
there and have one yeah uh so Tom and
Raquel chatted off stage by the trailers
looks like they took a break from
recording they're both head to toe in
Black which is probably a coincidence
but a very odd one uh he's having his
cigarette and drinking a diet coke and
she is
talking to him it's unclear it doesn't
look harmonious it also doesn't look
acrimonious it just looks like a
conversation good use of the word
acrimonious
neither harmonious nor acrimonious no we
got nothing we got nothing from those
photos they just look like they're like
they're genuinely just taking a break
they don't look particularly disheveled
or distraught or in love it's giving
nothing but we also got Paparazzi
pictures of Ariana showing up to the
reunion she I guess showed up like in
full Glam her hair makeup she looked
sickening yeah they all did they do
their makeup at home and stuff and then
she showed up in a boy's lie sweatsuit
which like you know you think nothing of
we wear them all the time but her thing
said 1-800 boys lie which I would have
just thought like oh boys I love that
brand but it means boys lie and like it
was created in the media like that
Ariana's sending the message that boys
lie I'm like honestly I feel like she
maybe didn't even think of it like those
sweat sets are just perfect it's just
like what you wear but I no I'm sure
like someone probably sent it to her
something like in the last few weeks and
it's like semi-coincidental yeah we do
now know like there are three different
setups you were saying the two different
seating charts but then there's also
just a one-on-one with Andy and Tom and
Ariana
oh and Tom and Ariana yeah okay so now I
want to talk about the seating charts
because they've put forth two reunion
seating charts which answer a lot of
questions especially about the Sheena
and Raquel I kind of just like figured
they'd figure it out but they haven't
they are abiding by the restraining
order and no of course but I'm glad that
doesn't mean anybody's doing Zoom no of
course but like they will not ever be
conversing which is crazy especially
when they're going to try and talk about
like the Schwartz Raquel Sheena Katie
drama yeah
it really sucks for Sheena because to be
honest any footage that they air that
doesn't have Raquel is not going to be
as good no it sucks for Sheena it really
does even though Sheena maintains her
innocence she says she did not punch
Raquel she said she pushed her yeah so a
few things about the legal stuff but
first here's the seating chart situation
one Andy in the middle on his left side
we have Ariana then Katie then James
then Lala
well I like getting shafted yeah I'm
surprised that Lala is not in front of
James I know I was thinking the same
thing but I'm sorry say what you want
James's commentary is [__] unmatched
like he's a star yes and James is very
germane to the Rock Tom situation and I
know Lala has made herself a main
character in the story but it it's not
logistically it's just not she she's not
as close to it and then on his right
side it goes Lisa Vanderpump Tom
Sandoval Raquel Tom Schwartz
damn that's rough seating for Raquel
yeah but it makes a lot of sense to me
and then when they switch his left side
stays the same Ariana Katie James Lala
his right side becomes
Lisa Tom Sandoval Tom Schwartz Sheena
yeah by the way this was training orders
like really kind of the worst thing to
happen to Sheena like she gets the worst
seat she doesn't get to be there half
the time
um and that just sucks yes so apparently
Raquel also served Sheena with some
papers at the reunion oh via Andy then
sheena's lawyer came out and said these
papers have no legal standing there's no
they haven't been filed with courts or
anything like there's no stamp on them
but correct me if I'm wrong like say I'm
serving you I don't know say a cease and
desist yeah do I have to file that
through a quarter it's like you better
see some [__] to Sister else we're
going to court
that's a good question and one I'm
ill-equipped to answer but also when you
serve someone with papers Andy can't
serve the person who serves people okay
he's like uh no no gesture of the court
so she was hand in papers not by Raquel
because obviously 100 feet have to be
between them 100 yards so Andy gave them
to Sheena
that doesn't seem like a legal servitude
no okay so change the word serve
okay so just like sin she was given
papers got it
um I don't understand a lot of the legal
elements going on because I know Lala
also a lot of the girls got papers from
Raquel's lawyers like a week or two ago
um I don't know what the what her legal
you know strategy is
because
like what's the end game there yeah I
mean her serving Sheena with a
restraining order was very extra but I
do feel like
it's a power movement yeah like it's
really throwing a wrench into everything
like that's just one less person who
gets to be there for the conversation
like it sucks for Sheena like Sheena has
been punished and if she did punch her
like she's being punished for punching
her and if she didn't then when the
restraining order you know continues on
its way Sheena has Witnesses she says
who will test it she didn't punch her
but no it sucks for Sheena like it
really sucks and it's honestly
surprising if she didn't punch Raquel
because even though everyone's gonna
come for Raquel like Sheena and her were
the the closest
I think what they're trying to say is
that China didn't punch Racquel but like
she pushed her yeah
but Raquel maintains that this scratch
on her eye is from Sheena yeah
and we saw the scar like it's like a
white little scar yeah we saw it on TMZ
we saw the picture that she allegedly
took that night where it was like red
and now it's like scarred over so it's
white
I don't know I don't know either
I just I what I do know is that I can't
wait like I cannot wait cannot wait but
every episode that leads us to that is
still Justice
just shocking and juicy I just hope that
they all the questions were asked and
all the questions were answered
yesterday
um they were just playing old episodes
of inner pump roles on Bravo and I was
enjoying them immensely it was uh the
year Brittany and Jax got married and
it's just if you now just like we just
know so much and going back and watching
it's just it's fascinating yeah
fascinating uh so then Andy also posted
a video after the reunion saying that
nothing was unsaid it was very
confrontational
and Andy's living for being at the
center of this like Bravo has not been
so relevant in maybe maybe ever honestly
in the cultural side guys no like I
would say like table flip
that was like a culture ship but that's
what it was 10 years ago but Bravo was
still so unknown
like it's just this is the biggest and
best thing to ever happen to the network
and I think Andy is absolutely loving
being at the center of it yeah and I
just hope that he was patient and
listened and asked all the questions
that we need to know yeah
I can't wait I can't wait can't wait are
you ready for our next story yeah
uh some drama between Olivia Wilde and
Jason Sudeikis in their custody case so
things are getting really nasty between
them but Olivia Wilde has had a win
Olivia Wilde scored a big victory in her
battle with Jason Sudeikis over child
custody and child support because TMZ
has learned a judge has just rejected
his request to have the case moved to
New York so Jason wage war with Olivia
trying to remove the custody dispute
from the California court to New York
because New York is typically less
generous with child support than
California but on Thursday New York
magistrate Adele Alexis Harris handed
down her decision that the court finds
that it is in the interest of
substantial Justice that the party's
child support petition be heard in
California it is a huge but costly move
for Olivia The Daily Mail obtained legal
docs filed by Olivia Thursday and
confirmed by TMZ in which her lawyers
say quote while Jason can afford to spin
his wheels with filing after filing
Olivia cannot Jason should not be
permitted to litigate Olivia into debt I
didn't realize
were so different yeah because she is
really successful wait I find that
shocking because he's much wealthier
than her yeah before you read that I
would say like
I was about to say
I can't imagine there's you know much to
argue over child support they're really
on the same level but how are they not
like what's their background and by the
way doesn't Olivia have Olivia has
family money yes Olivia comes from
wealth or I don't know what sort of
wealth but we know she comes from
connections but sometimes that doesn't
mean like actual liquid dollars and me
like who knows that her parents are like
I think that's irrelevant
um Olivia is very successful but I feel
like a lot of the things that she does
are like independent projects you know
she's a director directs these movies
that are very critically acclaimed but
not super commercially successful like
he is Ted lasso he does all these like
big comedy movies those are the things
that make money when you think about it
it makes more sense that way it does
he's much more like mainstream and she's
like an artist artist no you're totally
right wow I never thought of it like
that like she's low-key poor I never
thought of it like that but they also
might be framing it that way of course
so that he has to pay more in child
support no of course and so that like
the judge knows like you know that could
be a strategy from them too like he's
doing all these filings and it's you
know it's an attempt to bankrupt me yeah
and so also Olivia's lawyers wrote in
the docs that they were scheduled to
start working with a family therapist in
California in mid-January they I thought
things were coming down and we're going
to be moving forward in a more amicable
respectful fashion instead I learned on
January 10 2023 that the entire time I
was negotiating the parenting time
schedule in California Jason was
plotting to proceed with the New York
child support proceeding behind my back
damn I mean they're very California I
think like there was no way they were
ever going to get they don't live in New
York yeah and by the way those were the
papers that she was served on stage they
stated that he was trying to remove the
custody case to New York anyway so this
is a win for her that it hasn't been
moved but it's just really sad that this
is so nasty and ongoing so bad and that
they're like bleeding and all so much
money into like these legal proceedings
like it's and by the way were they ever
married or they were just thinking like
a long-term engagement
I don't think that they were married
yeah
I mean we actually just Google it
so that and that's still because that
would have been a whole other layer of
divorce like alimony right
he never tied the knot mm-hmm
this is crazy
crazy
I feel like they just need to meet up
and talk about it I know I feel like you
know
perhaps it might have been amicable but
I definitely think the Harry Styles of
it all like made it way worse because it
just it it was so crazy
so you think he's mad Jason I think
there's definitely resentment and I
think it's you know manifesting Jason is
dating someone now and he seems like he
has that she started dating someone like
so much more famous so much younger
literally a week later yeah like that's
gotta hurt it's an ego thing and these
are celebrities yeah that's true and
it's like it's [__] Harry Styles like
kill me now you think that's how Jason
Sudeikis feels about Harry Styles
not about Harry Styles necessarily but
like you're a celebrity there's so much
ego involved when you're an actor he's
the star of a show yada yada he's got
the girl yadda and
yeah your girl goes out with somebody so
much more famous than you so much
younger so handsome how can you not I'm
sorry that's just no human nature that's
human nature and I feel like when it's
women it's totally feels like that but
for me like I think I'd rather date
Jason Sudeikis and Harry Styles well
that's nice of you to say but I don't
know if many people would agree with
that sound off in the comments who do
you think is the bigger catch
bigger cats like no not even bigger
catch because we're thinking that's like
to settle down with which you rather be
with who would turdy rather be with I
feel like Harry Styles yeah of course
but I do also see your side like if I'm
really thinking about who do I want to
settle down have kids with and live a
long life with yeah Jason Sudeikis who's
older more mature more settled down like
of course I get it Harry's like rock
star you know cocaine like I get it yeah
but if we're just talking about looks
right but are we ever just talking about
looks turdy no and I feel like Jason's
dick is probably like an amazing
personality like I get it yeah he's Ted
lasso yeah
Peach I'm energy yeah but I I might that
might be a hot take that Jason Sudeikis
that's by the way thank you thank you
that's a hot take let's just start
pointing them out so people we need to
educate these but there's two different
types of hot takes one that's just like
the unpopular opinion and two like one
level get you canceled yeah of course of
course of course this is just like
something I don't think it would be the
popular opinion but sound of your
comments yeah there's really no bad
choice when we're choosing between these
two by the way new to season no there's
no bad choice and I Harry Styles I would
I would be so happy to date you as well
right I want to kick him out of bed
either
there's the new season of Ted lasso
which is so annoying because Ben's not
home and he hasn't been home like for
two weeks and I can't watch it without
him and I'm so excited
it's when does it come out it's out
since when like two days ago [__] I
should have watched you yesterday oh
[__] yeah
I guess I think Zach watches it too
so maybe we'll come together for it
right on the night's head Vanderpump
isn't on
Vanderpump he's obsessed I know you guys
Zach comes into the bedroom every night
is Vander pop out tonight and then
finally on Wednesday like after we put
Harry down I was he was so tired and I
was like by the way Vanderpump is on
tonight he's like you're lying I said no
that's how like the channels work so
cute so he's obsessed so that's been
that's been nice do you see um Talon I
think from old Laguna Beach he like did
a tick tock video talking about how the
Vander Scandal has brought him and his
wife together like I didn't see that oh
like it's just they talk about it all
the time like there's so many things to
say there's so many like podcasts to
listen to there is and I feel like we
don't Zach and I don't talk about the
things that are happening like off
screen he just like loves the show now
it's such a good show it's such a good
show
Zach sees you know he sees quality he
does
him for that are you ready for our next
story which is going to be some more
quality content no no no why are you
okay turdy luya no I will bust
if I don't tell everyone that today's
episode is brought to you by fashion
pass we have been fashion past girls for
years and if there was ever a time to
sign up for fashion pass it is now with
fashion pass you get unlimited rentals
which is amazing because most of the
clothing rental services out there only
offer eight or ten items per month which
is just so limiting and something if it
doesn't fit or you don't love it you
just out of luck but with fashion pass
you can literally swap out your pieces
as many times a month as you want we
were just talking about the fact that
influencers are always having a new
outfit remember like how do they do it
so many influencers use fashion pass
this is their secret because you save so
much money because you're not buying
clothes online all the time and they
carry the best brands for me that's what
sets fashion pass apart like I'm
constantly seeing rental services that
just have a granny
Smith moomoo's like it's just not the
vibe but they carry for love and Lemons
at Fashion pass free people show me your
MooMoo our favorite Amanda upper church
so many more
um So the plan that we are on is the
trendsetter plan so you get four
clothing items per order but you can
switch those
um as much as you want it's not like one
order per month so you basically just
get new clothes every week they ship
really fast they take care of dry
cleaning so you just send it back in the
pre-labeled bag and they give you
uh your new items so it couldn't be
easier one of our favorite Parts is that
if you love anything you can buy
directly from Fashion pass which saves
you money because you can get anywhere
from 30 to 60 off it's also just good
you know you're not contributing to you
know the endless consumerism of fast
fashion so you guys need to stop wasting
money and start using fashion pass if
you go to fashionpass.com toast use code
toast at checkout you'll get sixty
dollars off your first month so you can
try it for literally 29 bucks that's
unlimited rentals for just 29 with code
toast today's episode is also brought to
you by vegamore so we've tried
everything to get that silky strong
healthy hair and when we say everything
we mean everything so if you are tired
of those ineffective hair treatments and
are hungry to try something that
actually works give it vegamore a try
like we did it completely transformed
our hair their clean and vegan approach
to hair health uses smart Botanicals to
promote visibly thicker fuller longer
hair with help from vegamore you can get
healthy beautiful looking hair without
the harmful chemicals all their products
are cruelty free and never contain
potentially harmful chemicals like
parabens or hormones JK you've been like
very you know specific about what you've
been bringing into your home and you are
obsessed with vegamore that's what I
read about you on page six I am I'm in
my clean girl era and I had to swap out
my shampoo and conditioner because they
were not clean especially in this
pregnancy like I really want to use as
many clean non-toxic products as
possible and luckily I had just gotten a
shipment from vegamore because we were
going to try them out as a sponsor and I
swapped over to them I have not looked
back it's so amazing and also knowing
that I'm not putting fragrance in my
hair any parfum anything you know
hormone disruptors anything like that
like it's just you get such peace of
mind while also not changing the quality
of your hair care so Jackie's using the
gro revitalizing shampoo and conditioner
kit it's fabulous I love their dry
shampoo
um 91 of customers uh say that they saw
visibly thicker hair with vegamore in
just three months so you won't want to
run out give your hair exactly what it's
been craving with vegamore go to
vagamore.com toast and use code toast to
save 20 on your first order that's
v-e-g-a-m-o
our.com slash toast code toast to save
20 off vagamore.com toast thank you
Claudia I'm glad that you got that off
your chest because I could tell it was
bothering you I feel better you it was
really pent up like bubbling beneath the
surface 100 our next story is some
really great book to TV news that we
need to dissect because it's an ensemble
cast and we've got some big names in
talks for the Netflix limited series for
the book oh it's not a movie okay I
thought I just assumed it was a movie no
this is so limited series like 100 it
opens with the wedding weekend and a
body in the water yeah who is it who did
it right so the book is the perfect
couple by Ellen Hildebrand Claudia and I
have both read it we love Ellen this is
like this book was more murder mystery
than Ellen usually goes for and it's
such a great book so if you want like a
a semi Thriller because it's like Ellen
peaceful Vibes with like yep just like a
murder hanging over it takes place on
beautiful Nantucket these young boys
people are planning their wedding it's
really it's gorgeous and I feel like
they'll make it pretty oh my God they'll
make it so pretty so I think it's ripe
for a limited series and here's who's in
talks for it Nicole Kidman I imagine she
would be playing the mother of the groom
because they're like he's like a from a
famous Nantucket wealthy family the
groom Liev Schreiber I'm gonna say the
father of husband right Megan Fahey
Dakota Fanning and Eve Houston who are
all young actresses so the two they're
big girls right they're the bride the
bride Celeste and her friend Merit
Merit yeah the Merit I always thought
was brunette so
yeah and they go they could all change
their hair but we have two blondes and
Celeste is definitely blonde I feel like
Megan Fahey is so the bride Megan Phoebe
he has to be the bride she's so the
bride like that's just so her it's so
her she's so Bridal yeah and the bride
is like kind of this like victim in a
sense like everything's going wrong
around her yeah yeah she is but she's
also not a little bit if you think about
like what she's been up to I don't
remember I'll tell you offline
um so I'm really hoping Megan [__] is a
bride there were some other Ancilla
characters you know like the the
sister-in-law maybe that's Dakota
Fanning but these are also the names
that were in talks so maybe not everyone
is confirmed but Megan Faye he did post
this article to her Instagram thus
confirming thus confirming that she's in
the movie no I think it confirms that
everyone's in it honestly like and also
a guy named Jack Rayner who I don't know
him he looks like Nicholas Holt and
imagine he's the groom room
this is such like a random book for them
to choose I loved this book um but I
don't feel like it's a book that has
like a particular cult following but you
know what I think that's better because
it's just a good plot for a TV show you
know yes they need it's not like a book
that people are in love with in the
sense that if they steer from the
original plot a little bit people will
be so offended it's just good bones for
a TV show because I don't even remember
every aspect of the original plot I just
remember like you know they can't do
this
sort of I remember I remember who done
it yeah yeah I think I remember too but
um it also will be directed and the
executive produced by Susan beer who did
the undoing so oh it should be good I
don't know for me Netflix doesn't have
like an amazing track record with book
adaptations like I didn't think lucky
scroll live was that great and maybe I'm
just protective of it because it's one
of my favorite books of all time and I'm
like one of those toxic reader fans but
I didn't think it was good and I don't
think a lot of people thought it was
good so I don't have like like there are
some networks where like I know they're
gonna do good work
um with with an adaptation and let me
ask you something what is a good book to
movie or show adaptation of a book that
you've read
okay I didn't read it though but like I
think where the crawdads was a great
adaptation it was and I can say I read
it and it was but of a book that you've
read because I feel like when you read
the book you always hate you don't like
the show because it there's it's never
gonna be Apples to Apples well here by
the way I hated Daisy Jones of the six
and I'm kind of liking the TV show it's
not amazing but it's good okay but of a
book that I hated the book I need a book
that you liked I don't know I feel like
I actually haven't I don't have a lot of
experiences with books and movies like I
either never read the book or they never
made my favorite book into a TV show you
know yeah all of the experiences that
I've had with books to shows and where
I've read the book I did not like the
show okay I got one I got one but it's
so Random The Hating game with Lucy Hale
no that's good uh I liked the book and I
liked the movie it wasn't a particularly
you know thought-provoking piece of work
either way it was just like a silly
rom-com yeah it was good they were both
good no it can be done it's not like a
beta complete that like it's gonna be
worse like a Theta complete like a
a certain ending
is it French it is no no I'm not
correcting you I'm asking no no it is
French I think let me Google
like a complete fate yeah like a certain
fate I'm obsessed a fader complete
it is
a thing that has already happened or
been decided before those affected hear
about it but like spell it for me
leaving them with no option to accept it
f-a-i-t
space
a-c-c-o-m-p-l-i
fera complete is so I don't think it's a
fatal complain that a book is going to
be a crappy movie or show I can set a
few examples even though I didn't read
but like worldwide success for Harry
Potter of course and I don't think Harry
Potter readers are like the shows you're
right Game of Thrones also Twilight
Twilight and for me Confessions of a
Shopaholic
forget that that was a book my one of my
favorite book series is ever one of my
favorite movies ever yeah so it can be
done I'm really hopeful for the perfect
couple even though it's not my favorite
book so I feel like and it's almost
better it's like a four-star read yeah I
guess I just actually you don't have so
much invested in it like your whole life
isn't on the line if it's not cast
exactly how you wanted it no and it does
feel like the type of show given like
Nicole Kidman and the undoing lady that
people will like just become obsessed
with not because of the book at all but
it's just a really good premise it's
like it's kind of like in the undoing it
was like did she didn't she did he
didn't he did it and this is really just
a whodunit it's a good
premise for a limited series like we
there's a crime in the beginning and
with the whole time it's like big little
lies big little lies except I thought
nine perfect strangers which was a book
I intentionally didn't read so that I
couldn't could enjoy the show I thought
the show was horrible I never even
finished it I watched the first episode
I'm like this is crap it was absolute
crap crap
anyways this is exciting news yeah I
like it yeah I hope it all chugs along
nicely looking forward and I think this
is also a really good I think a lot of
people have been wondering what's Megan
Fahey gonna do next like she had this
breakout role she's been kind of quiet
just like being a fabulous it girl Ralph
Lauren Emmys Oscars whatever and we were
curious what does Megan Fahey gonna do
next and this is it and I think this is
great no and unfortunately like in
Hollywood like if you're not doing on to
the next unless you read like once
you've already reached a certain level
like you could take some time off but
like
we need to know what's next to her your
career is a series of moves and we
needed to know her next move and this is
a strong next move agreed Lev Schreiber
Netflix undoing Nicole Kidman Dakota
it's very it's premium it's a list it's
perfect premium are you ready for our
fifth and final story just some
heartwarming news Okay Mason Ramsey took
a fan to prom and posted about it on
Tick Tock and reels and it was really
quite beautiful so one of his fans
commented like made somebody go to prom
with me and he was like sure and so he
went to her house picked her up I forgot
she's oh her name is Ella literally
gorgeous she's gorgeous she's such a
pretty 16 year old age-appropriate like
literally should be his girlfriend so
they took pictures her dad came out with
a gun you know like you better take care
of my girl uh he had a nice Escalade for
her they went to prom I'm dead I'm dead
they went to pre-prom took pictures with
like all of her friends Mason was very
generous with his time taking pictures
with everyone they went to the prom they
danced then someone else asked Ella to
dance so like Mason boogied the night
away with everyone else at the school
because you know why not but then he
took Ella home back to her father
because he promised that he would she
had a curfew
but like the way I'm praying that these
two are still talking she's beautiful
yeah um he's really coming into his own
they kind of look like siblings but like
in a good way yeah in the way that like
you and Ben look like siblings right 100
100 I'm obsessed I love this I feel like
I don't know if
it's been intentional like as a strategy
but the way that Mason Ramsey has grown
up very normally continued to release
music and stay relevant and like post
content to social media but not to the
point where it's like sad or has been or
too much he is being
I don't know if he's being managed but
if he is it's to Perfection I feel like
we talk about him once every six months
like it's yeah because he does something
viral intentionally viral but it like
hits and goes viral in a good way it's
all very sweet and good-natured content
I think he does have management and he's
I think he's signed with good people
when he rose to yodeling Fame I remember
like Florida Georgia Line was working
with him I think I think everybody
really looked out for him and and he
somehow landed with just like good
people who are allowing him to live his
life grow up and there is a big career
waiting for him whenever he decides that
he wants it but like he still only 16
like there's more school to be done he
works at Subway he still he actually he
owns the subway but he works there too
he still uh probably lives with his
grandparents like I think this is all so
good and I look forward to whatever
music he puts out one day because I
think he's actually truly talented oh my
God I think in order to have a long
successful illustrious career of these
years are really important that he has
like normalcy and is able to mature I
agree and I think like when you boil it
down too like you strip away you know
The Yodeling and whatever and he's
extremely talented and so much of the
music that he puts out I mean that song
like I actually cry when I hear it
um my way up the mountain I wanna look
around and tune in every sunset before
it fades as fast as I am going I want to
stop and smell the roses and [__] never
me I have made on my way it's beautiful
song it's a beautiful song you guys
should listen to it we whenever we talk
about him we talk about this one song
because he put out an EP of all good
songs and also one of them went viral on
tick tock
uh before I knew it I was holding all
the doors holding her hand getting off
of work just as fast as I can calling
you up calling what you doing who before
I knew it right so and that's not even
the best song in the album the best song
on the album is on my way and it's just
a signal of what's to come for him so I
hope he
graduate high school he had said on
Ellen he wanted to go to college
remember she laughed at his big dream of
going to college [__] Ellen that was
really by the way when I was [__]
done with Ellen she was so nasty go back
and watch that interview and just look
at how condescending and like Loki rude
Ellen was to the yodel kid like why yeah
no because she was like what do you like
because she grants wishes whatever and
His Wish was to go to college so [__]
what a pure answer and shouldn't we be
encouraging the youth to stay in school
she like mocked him that really bothered
me yeah it bothered me too I obviously
haven't forgotten about it I hope he
goes to college and then gets in the
studio with FGL anyone else he got close
with Brian Kelly not the point Sky of
former Florida Georgia Line Fame because
he's like a big songwriter in addition
to being one half of FGL he like writes
a lot of songs further everyone who's
successful in country music is also a
big songwriter right and he wrote some
songs for Mason Ramsey I think they were
a really good Duo and I think you know
Brian Kelly's like a good guy he
probably looked out for Mason I hope
they work together again yeah I I hope
so too but as I stated it's all waiting
for him and this is a great segue to
talk about some other country music that
dropped today
getting old the album by Luke Combs is
here how much Have you listened to I
listen to it I think maybe almost all
the way through while I was getting
ready but it was it was very much in the
background I didn't I wasn't focused
yeah I listened I got up to my song will
never die oh my God by the way I think I
literally got up to the same but it's a
huge album I think we're only halfway
through oh real oh yeah I forgot it's 18
songs let me see and there were like
definitely a few that immediately caught
my eye yeah like Hannaford Road
just popped off my songs will never die
I loved and still
oh I didn't even get to listen to The
Fast Car [__] I have been waiting listed
in an order attorney I know the way that
Luke intended for Luke Holmes to release
a cover of Fast Car by Tracy Chapman
because that was like one of the First
videos he ever did that went viral and
it's like a song there's a few covers he
does that are like really famous in
Luke's stand-up that's one of them Jack
and Diane by Teddy Mellencamp's dad is
it's funny how like my initial I
automatically said Teddy Mellencamp not
John Mellencamp yeah um is one of the
best covers I need him to release John
Mellencamp has become like a nepo father
he's only he's only famous because of
his daughter teddy well these days like
kind of no like she was just I literally
just saw an article about her this
morning that she took her kids to a John
Mellencamp concert yeah no her and her
daughter close it's really nice and he
is like America's sweetheart John Cougar
Mellencamp yeah no he's like he's like a
Bruce
he's like a Bruce yeah people are I feel
like but I think he eats meals today
east coast and John Mellencamp is like
West Coast do you get that Vibe no okay
I don't cool
but sound off in the comments if you do
like I could be wrong I don't know that
much about either of them
long after the thrill of living is gone
I need Luke combs's cover he like did it
in a bar once and it went like so viral
you guys need to watch it and I need him
like next album can't do like two covers
on one album I agree so we got fast car
I need Jack and Diane okay
tell him just putting it out in the
universe I so I can't really give any
full statements on my thoughts it's
incredible but like I need to really
marry live with it yeah I got to do a
lot of driving this weekend so I can
listen to it see that's what I'm gonna
do today I think there's some other
music out but like I can't focus on
anything besides the music who Luke
music comb day it's girl get an old day
so that is our show our final one of the
week I hope you guys have an amazing
weekend recover rejuvenate restore heal
because Monday's right around the corner
like not to be like such a you know a
favor you're one of those honestly
Monday is a fade to come play it's a
fatal complain so just like understand
what's coming and live in the moment
okay like WWE nkd what would Norma
Kamali do what would Nicole Kidman do
love you guys what are you doing this
weekend turdy Lou just being alone oh
yeah I'm sorry I asked yeah you should
be
okay so I'm having dinner with Brian
tonight so that's something yeah that's
cool going somewhere fabulous yeah of
course and you're not being alone you're
taking care of Theo that's why you have
your stay home and I'm taking care of me
turdy's number one
always always
thank you guys so much for listening to
the toast the millennial Morning Show
where we deliver the past episodes
available
videos
talented we are hope you guys have an
amazing day and we'll see you on Monday
bye love you bye